c'est un rapport qui pourrait faire du
bruit une note confidentielle de la cour
des comptes a dressé à la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale
elle concerne les enseignants et la
mauvaise gestion du mammouth de
l'éducation nationale il y aurait
aujourd'hui 32000 profs qui ne verraient
pas d'élèves ce qui coûterait un
milliard et demi d'euros aux
contribuables
nabila taboury et benoît bringer la
prochaine rentrée se prépare
actuellement ouvertures ou fermetures de
classes les recteurs sont en pleine
réflexion
la nouvelle pourrait donc faire du bruit
l'équivalent de 32 mille postes
d'enseignants sur 660 5000 aurait été
gaspiller en 2003-2004 où sont donc
passés ces professeurs 100 élèves
la plupart sont des remplaçants avec des
périodes sans activité certains ont des
décharges syndicales
d'autres sont détachés dans des
fondations ou des associations fait top
et à gérer dans le chiffre des 32000
dans le détail dans l'analyse c'est long
mais en show justifier des actions qui
sont à prendre c'est le total général
surtout d'être en 2000 qui effectivement
fait un effet masse et parce que des
rapprochements qui nous semblent abusifs
qui peut jurer justifier son fait
l'éducation nationale emploie 6 %
d'enseignants sur effectifs pour faire
face aux remplacements au delà de ce
chiffre
les professeurs sont en surnombre selon
la cour des comptes cela équivaut à 2450
postes à temps plein on retrouve ces
sureffectif dans des disciplines telles
que l'allemand la philo mais aussi le
génie civil et l'électronique
les syndicats enseignants conteste ces
chiffres et dénoncent un amalgame les
enseignants qui sont dans des situations
diverses non standard mais qui
travaillent et qui font des activités
qui relèvent du service public
ces 32 mille postes coûterait 1,5
milliard d'euros aux contribuables soit
la moitié du budget de la culture
et un attentat 7